[Music]
so
when i decided i wanted a dog i started
looking online
and i quickly decided that a jack
russell was right for me
because i had grown up with one so i
figured okay i can do that again
they're a special greed but at least i
know how to handle all that energy there
are times where i've taught him things
like high five where it took
maybe three repetitions before he got it
right away he never stops impressing me
with not only what he learns but how
quickly he learns it
when quarantine started i got laid off
and so i went from getting up and
working every day to
suddenly not doing that so that was
tough but the thing with the dog is
he had to get up and he had to do the
same also because that's the way he's
wired
so instead of moping we started going on
hikes this week we did
seven miles if it weren't for him i
don't think i would get outside very
much i'm just really thankful for this
little guy
working together keeps both of us
physically and
mentally healthy during all this
[Music]
hi i'm cammy and my dog's name is zara
she's an akita mix
with shepherd the previous owner
surrendered her at the pound so for the
first month
at her home she was really kind of sad
and really clingy
and then she just opened up like she
just knew that we weren't gonna let her
go
she's got me on a schedule okay because
we're in quarantine
i don't know what day of the week it is
i don't know what time it is but she's
like mom it's time to eat
you ready to eat okay she's awesome
juan carlos is a miniature pinscher and
he's three years old juan carlos has a
very quirky personality
hey it's time to get up he does not like
people touching his things
he will always tell you what he wants
he's very vocal
let's go for a walk
he's so smart if he had thumbs the
things he would do part of my job as
nutritionist is developing healthy
recipes and he is
a really great sous chef and he really
motivates me to always get in there and
get creative
and he just loves being in the kitchen
as much as i do he's my best friend in
the whole world and i'm just so glad he
came into my life
are you glad that you came into my life
[Music]
okay
hi i'm carolina and this is my
one-year-old golden doodle labradoodle
mix
luna she is the best dog i've ever met
also the craziest
she's helped me a lot during pointing
because my roommate has been gone
whether it's watching a movie with her
cuddling giving her a bath taking her on
a walk she keeps me
busy all day at times when i'm not so
busy we're all at home
and it feels like every day would look
the same if it weren't for her
i'm very grateful she's chewing on my
arm right now but i swear she's a nice
dog i've been training her during
quarantine
sit out hey mom no
jonah don't ask me how it's going
oh you're so cute
[Applause]
i love you
you